un appareil a été mise au point
récemment dans ce centre de recherche
international
c'est une machine à faire du café une
machine très simple d'un côté un
appareil électrique de l'autre un petit
paquet rond en papier l'aluminium
contenant de l'eau et du café séparés
par une membrane quand l'eau est chaude
la membrane ce père c'est le café se
mélangent à l'eau
béchir de ce truc là encore toujours
fier sans enfant
cet appareil lui a coûté deux ans et
demi de recherches
l'exemplaire unique est un prototype
mais si je pouvais vraiment j'achète
mais par rapport à tout ce qu'on connaît
enfin tous les appareils qu'on connaît
ça qu'il est davantage
sa part confrontée la commodité la
rapidité
la qualité du café
aussi le fait que la route ibilité
pourrait-on dire c'est à dire que chaque
tasse est égale à elle même ne pas rater
du café puisque toutes les conditions
d'opération sont
réglées par le processus lui-même la
température de l'eau la durée de passage
et d'assister à la rupture d'actifs
normal
on joue c'est une trouvaille
véritable découverte
dans cette une innovation pour autant
qu'elle trouve son débouché industriel
nous espérons vivre jusqu'à la porte au
projet un élément de confort
pas plaisir
est ce que c'est c'est renner
[Applaudissements]
déjà eu du plaisir à faire ça sa
trouvaille est déjà en soi même je pense
que c'est déjà une motivation à table
et en allemand alors est ce qu est ce qu
un chercheur ne s'interroge pas sur
sur la finalité finalement de son
travail
je prends pas chercheur se pose ce genre
de question j'ai pas l'impression il a
suffisamment pris part de travail qui
fait
quoi qui tiendra lieu le motif voulait
dire que ce qu'il découvre est plus
important que l'usa en france a
découvert très probable certainement là
avec sur de la majorité des chercheurs
[Musique]